i want to talk about this photo of harry
and megan michelle because
they look so in love look at the way
she's leaning on him
i know just so comfortable together you
know it's their first official photo
since exiting their roles as senior
royals now this is all for tomorrow's
time 100 talks
they're going to be hosting it meanwhile
there's new drama for the royal family
thanks to a new book
zeroing in on the so-called battle
between brothers
we have two emotionally damaged young
men here
with the advent of megan that was what
provoked the really big break
william was so upset with the speed of
harry falling for megan that the book
claims he actually called on diana's
brother for a summit
called the spencer intervention it's a
pretty bold move to go and get diane's
brother charles to bring him in to quote
unquote try to talk some sense
into harry harry rejected williams model
he knew what he wanted he loved this
woman um and he was going to marry her
in his new book battle of brothers out
tomorrow robert lacy writes there is
more behind prince william's royal smile
a lot of people close to the scene would
say well you know that william has a
temper
he would get angry with his father
charles when
he didn't feel that charles was doing
the right thing as a future king
williams hot head apparently came into
play when he the queen
charles and harry were scheduled to meet
this past january to hash out details of
mexic
harry went to the lunch william was so
furious he
refused to go to the lunch there is
certainly a school of thought william
and kate were not happy at the way in
which
these royal rock stars harry and megan
overshadowed them
and that they're quite happy now to see
them out of the country